according to the ich gcp guidelines
there are four key roles in the clinical
trial process
the ethics committee representing the
regulatory authority
the sponsor initiating and financing the
project
the investigator conducts the research
and the monitor responsible for
monitoring the clinical trial
investigator is usually a physician in
practice who participates in these
studies
he is usually responsible for ensuring
that an investigation is conducted
according to the signed investigator
statement
the investigational plan and applicable
regulations
such as protecting the right safety and
welfare of subjects
under the investigator's care and for
the control of drugs under investigation
the clinical trial investigators could
be divided into three main types
principal investigator the scientist in
charge of an experiment
or research project co-principal
investigator and co-investigator
a person who shares the direction and
responsibility for a proposed project
faculty participant a faculty
participant may also be referred to as a
faculty investigator or senior personnel
and usually participates in clinical
trials when they are being conducted in
university hospitals
the investigator should be qualified by
education training
and experience to assume responsibility
for the proper conduct of the trial
should meet all the qualifications
specified by the applicable regulatory
requirements
and should provide evidence of such
qualifications through up-to-date
curriculum vitae and other relevant
documentation requested by the sponsor
the irb and the regulatory authorities
the investigators should be thoroughly
familiar with the appropriate use of the
investigational products
as described in the protocol in the
product information
and in other information sources
provided by the sponsor
he or she should be aware of and comply
with gcp
and the applicable regulatory
requirements
the investigator or institution should
permit monitoring and auditing by the
sponsor
and inspection by the appropriate
regulatory authorities
the investigator should maintain a list
of appropriately qualified persons to
whom the investigator has delegated
significant trial related duties
the investigator should be able to
demonstrate a potential for recruiting
the required number of suitable subjects
within the agreed recruitment period
the investigator should have sufficient
time to properly conduct and complete
the trial within the agreed trial period
the investigator should have available
an adequate number of qualified staff
and adequate facilities for the foreseen
duration of the trial
to conduct the trial properly and safely
the investigator should ensure that all
persons assisting with the trial are
adequately informed about the protocol
the investigational products and their
trial related duties and functions the
investigator is also responsible for
supervising any individual or party to
whom the investigator delegates trial
related duties and functions conducted
at the trial site
a qualified physician or dentist who is
an investigator or a sub-investigator
for the trial
should be responsible for all
trial-related medical or dental
decisions
during and following a subject's
participation in a trial
the investigator and institution should
ensure that adequate medical care is
provided to a subject for any adverse
events
including clinically significant
laboratory values related to the trial
the investigator and institution should
inform a subject when medical care
is needed for inter-current illnesses of
which the investigator becomes aware
it is recommended that the investigator
inform the subject's primary physician
about the subject's participation in the
trial if the subject has a primary
physician
and if the subject agrees to the primary
physician being informed
although a subject is not obliged to
give his or her reasons for withdrawing
prematurely from a trial
the investigator should make a
reasonable effort to ascertain the
reasons
while fully respecting the subjects
rights
before initiating a trial the
investigator and institution should have
written
and dated approval or favorable opinion
from the irb for the trial protocol
written in formed consent form consent
form updates
subject recruitment procedures such as
advertisements and any other written
information to be provided to subjects
as part of the investigator's written
application to the irb
the investigators should provide the irb
with a current copy of the
investigator's brochure
if the investigator's brochure is
updated during the trial
the investigator should supply a copy of
the updated investigator's brochure to
the irb
during the trial the investigator should
provide to the irb
all documents subject to review
the investigator should conduct the
trial in compliance with the protocol
agreed to by the sponsor
and if required by the regulatory
authorities and which was given approval
or favorable opinion by the irb
the investigator or institution and the
sponsor should sign the protocol
or an alternative contract to confirm
agreement
the investigator should not implement
any deviation from
or changes of the protocol without
agreement by the sponsor
and prior review and documented approval
or favorable opinion from the irb of an
amendment
except where necessary to eliminate an
immediate hazards to trial subjects
or when the changes involves only
logistical or administrative aspects of
the trial
such as change in monitors change of
telephone numbers and etc
the investigator or person designated by
the investigator
should document and explain any
deviation from the approved protocol
the investigator may implement a
deviation from the protocol
to eliminate an immediate hazard to
trial subjects without prior irb
approval
as soon as possible the implemented
deviation or change
the reasons for it and the proposed
protocol amendments
should be submitted to the irb for
review and approval to the sponsor for
agreement and to the regulatory
authorities
responsibility for investigational
product accountability at the trial
sites rests with the investigator or
institution
where allowed or required the
investigator or institution
may assign some or all of the
investigators duties for investigational
products accountability at the trial
sites to an appropriate pharmacist or
another appropriate individual who is
under the supervision of the
investigator or institution
the investigator or institution or a
pharmacist or other appropriate
individual
who is designated by the investigator or
institution
should maintain records of the product's
delivery to the trial site
the inventory at the site the use by
each subject
and the return to the sponsor or
alternative disposition of unused
products
these records should include dates
quantities batch or serial numbers
expiration dates and the unique code
numbers assigned to the investigational
products and trial subjects
investigators should maintain records
that document adequately that the
subjects were provided the doses
specified by the protocol and reconcile
all investigational products received
from the sponsor
the investigational products should be
stored as specified by the sponsor
and in accordance with applicable
regulatory requirements
the investigator should ensure that the
investigational products are used only
in accordance with the approved protocol
the investigator or a person designated
by the investigator or institution
should explain the correct use of the
investigational products to each subject
and should check
at intervals appropriate for the trial
that each subject is following the
instructions properly
in obtaining and documenting informed
consent the investigators should comply
with the applicable regulatory
requirements
and should adhere to gcp and to the
ethical principles that have their
origin in the declaration of helsinki
prior to the beginning of the trial the
investigators should have the irb's
written approval of the written informed
consent form and any other written
information to be provided to subjects
any revised written informed consent
form and written information should
receive the irb's approval in advance of
use
the subject or the subject's legally
acceptable representative should be
informed in a timely manner if new
information becomes available that may
be relevant to the subject's willingness
to continue participation in the trial
the communication of this information
should be documented
neither the investigator nor the trial
staff should coerce or unduly influence
a subject to participate
or to continue to participate in a trial
none of the oral and written information
concerning the trial
including the written informed consent
form should contain any language that
causes the subject or the subjects
legally acceptable representative to
waive or to appear to waive any legal
rights that releases release the
investigator
the institution the sponsor or their
agents from liability for negligence
the language used in the oral and
written information about the trial
including the written informed consent
form should be as non-technical as
possible and should be understandable to
the subject or the subject's legally
acceptable representative
and the impartial witness were
applicable
before informed consent may be obtained
the investigator
or a person designated by the
investigator should provide the subject
or the subject's legally acceptable
representative ample time and
opportunity to inquire about details of
the trial
and to decide whether or not to
participate in the trial
all questions about the trial should be
answered to the satisfaction of the
subject or the subject's legally
acceptable representative
prior to a subject's participation in
the trial the written informed consent
form should be signed and personally
dated by the subject or by the subject's
legally acceptable representative
and by the person who conducted the
informed consent discussion
all serious adverse events or sae should
be reported immediately to the sponsor
except for those saes that the protocol
or other document
such as the investigator's brochure
identifies as not needing immediate
reporting
the immediate report should be followed
promptly by detailed
written reports the investigator should
also comply with the applicable
regulatory requirements related to the
reporting of unexpected serious adverse
drug reactions to the regulatory
authorities and the irb
for reported deaths the investigator
should supply the sponsor
and the irb with any additional
requested information
such as autopsy reports and terminal
medical reports
if the trial is prematurely terminated
or suspended for
any reason the investigator or
institution should promptly inform the
trial subjects
should assure appropriate therapy and
follow-up for the subjects
and were required by the applicable
regulatory requirements
should inform the regulatory authorities
if the investigator terminates or
suspends a trial without prior agreement
of the sponsor
the investigator should inform the
institution where applicable
and the investigator or institution
should promptly inform the sponsor
and the irb and should provide the
sponsor and the irb a detailed written
explanation of the termination or
suspension
if the sponsor terminates or suspends a
trial the investigator should promptly
inform the institution where applicable
and the investigator or institution
should promptly inform the irb
and provide the irb a detailed written
explanation of the termination
or suspension if the irb terminates or
suspends its approval of a trial
the investigator should inform the
institution where applicable
and the investigator or institution
should promptly notify the sponsor and
provide the sponsor with a detailed
written explanation of the termination
or suspension
upon completion of the trial the
investigator should inform the
institution
provide the irb with a summary of the
trial's outcome
and provide any report as required by
the regulatory authorities
in summary investigators are responsible
for ensuring the investigation is
conducted according to the
investigational plan
directly responsible for protecting the
trial subjects
obtaining the informed consent of human
subjects and controlling the
investigational drug